toujours au commencement il y à une
armature le grillage et découpé tordue
il donne la forme ensuite seulement
vient le ciment il s'accroche par
petites touches pour créer une attitude
c'est toujours à l'arrêt dans le temps
une expression un arrêt dans un
mouvement
j'observe beaucoup les gens dans la rue
un peu partout et je photographie dans
ma tête et ensuite je viens je viens ça
ressort
claerbout rice habille ses personnages
de ciment un matériau brut et robuste
qui va durer une façon pour elle de
défier le temps
les sculptures effectivement seront là
vont vieillir dans le jardin il va
falloir quand même plusieurs hivers pour
obtenir une petite patine après ça
dépend c11 brésil 9 dieu au dessus
mais elles vont vieillir et tous les ans
ils vont changer se transformer par la
nature
voici le peuple de claire des
personnages et lancer des formes épurées
le reflet de ce que l'artiste ressent du
monde et des hommes
nous cherchons à instaurer un dialogue
entre l'art et la nature et le travail
de claire et d'un travail d'arrêt sur
images quasiment et est à l'arrêt est en
arrêt sur image et un travail sur
l'équilibré en le dialogue et la
confrontation se 7 en 2008
les sculptures de claire non pas de
regard pas donné unis de bush et
pourtant elles nous parlent à leur
manière
pour moi c'est vraiment c'est toujours
le mouvement s'est pas forcément de
marquer un regard c'est vraiment le
mouvement a besoin de montrer une
expression sur le visage pas besoin de
gauche pour parler